[Music]
all right guys you know
how we are in a pandemic and a lot of we
are have
had to change the way they do their
business or
not just that but then like a lot of new
ideas and how to do business have
sprouted and popular companies like
amazon uber and grubhub they have relied
heavily on convenience and that's why
they're six
they're very successful right now um and
so
this one detroit entrepreneur he decided
to bring bowling to the masses so he
converted this 53-foot semi-truck
trailer truck oh cool into a mobile
bowling alley
that's dumb yeah but he's been working
on this for years
but um luckily now he's finally been
able to complete this project
even through the pandemic because there
were a ton of obstacles because of
the pandemic but now he has a two-lane
facility
and it was recently unveiled so uh it's
called
luxury strike bowling so you could he
takes his truck
yeah that's not full length right
no so it is shorter and the balls are
smaller so you they have to oh so it's
like the [ __ ] you see at like round one
or something right or like arcades yeah
i don't think it's that small
no it's not that small like i'll show
you a video no not like skee-ball but
like there's a lot of arcades that have
like
a bowling alley but like you can like
palm the bowling ball
like that kind of thing uh yeah oh
you could check out the video here we go
i like the sound of
when it hits the panel love that sound i
never hear that
[Music]
puts it back in place we got to set it
up and the old one is experience
jackson jr of southfield to your desired
location or doorstep
that's entrepreneur world's first mobile
bowling alley and
we're built right here in the detroit
the bowling alley is made of
a 53-foot conversion trailer that we
actually
designed specifically for
this type of setting when you come in
our facility you will see
a luxury bowling alley that you can
connect via bluetooth to our
state-of-the-art sound system
and also our theater we have available
and you'll be able to control all the
temperature inside while you enjoy it
our lanes are a scale down but they're
about
30 feet long our balls are a little bit
smaller
scaled down three and a half to four
inches but you can still get a great
strike out of it
when you come into luxury strike bowling
you will get a luxury interaction
experience
you can actually bring whatever
beverages you desire on board and enjoy
with your guests
we are totally different concept from
the traditional bowling alley
that's cool cool so i first was
imagining this as like
the back of a truck being open so you're
like bowling outside but that looks like
an enclosed
truck still it's like a vip yeah the vip
lounge that was like it looks like a
room
it opens the truck door it's like gavin
newsom eating outside so yeah
just open the truck door you'll be fine
damn that's so cool
i love seeing all these businesses and
entrepreneurs get really creative i
think that's great to still figure out
ways to make things work
i do wish one of the things that like
happened with this pandemic is the uh
contactless delivery i wish that stays
forever because i don't like talking
to people where i get my food from i'm
just like i just just leave it there
have you had people knock on your window
no i've had people do that they'd be
like hey
hey it's here anymore i just started
cooking a way more now
so dude bowling needs this update anyway
because it's always so [ __ ] long and
i suck so much at bowling like i need
this
this little handicap i don't know i
don't like it i've built in places that
like aren't
standard and i'm like [ __ ] this place so
this this like comes
to your house for like a party or
whatever yeah if you live in detroit
damn it yeah and they just leave it
there and you could just
damn man stores are gonna start coming
to you now
yeah we're gonna be wall-e it's gonna be
wall-e in real life
yeah look check it out this is what it
looks like on the outside
that's pretty cool so it's like hitched
to a truck
do you guys ever did you guys ever have
like a vegetable man that would come in
like a um
it's kind of like a lunch truck or like
an ice cream truck kind of thing
and then they just had a grocery store
like in their
truck mexico they have a whole bakery
yeah bakery come to your place in
certain grocery store parking lots they
have
people doing that yeah he's he so like
maybe it was a japanese community thing
but he would just have um gross like
produce delivery so you just send in and
you call in you're like you're uh what
you want or
if he parks on your street it's like the
ice cream man you can just walk up
and then i used to go with my grandma
and then she would just have a box
of like all the vegetables and things
that she ordered and then he would drop
it off but he would also have [ __ ] in
his truck and you can pick it out
and he's like oh we have fresh peaches
and grapes and whatever and i'm like i
want that
that's tight yeah i should do that right
now that would be sick i would i would
so go to like the grocery store truck
like an ice cream shop
because in mexico they have like an ice
cream and type of thing but it's
it's a bakery so then they go around the
neighborhoods and they yell
bye
it sounds like a car alarm
the pan pizza very popular very very
popular
and pizza in mexico no italy i was like
what
fun pizza but yeah that's just so cool
so then you run out and you just go get
a whole bunch of like conchas
and stuff it's like really gorgeous i
like the mexican bakery it's got a lot
of things
that you can just grab with the tongs
and you put it in a bag
it's like it's like fake croissant it's
just a croissant shape but it's like
hard as [ __ ]
it's like dude until i had asian bread
did i realize that
sweet bread could be soft as [ __ ] oh
yeah especially the
japanese stuff dude mexican bread is
hella heavy
it's just dense yeah it's just really
dead cardboard
it goes good with coffee though it's
good with coffee yeah it's all hard and
dry
and then coffee yeah you got to get
really fresh and then that's because i
had always like
tried to get as fresh as i could and
it's soft when it's fresh but when it's
not fresh
you can it's like rock yeah you could
put it in a bag and whack someone with
it parody
asian bread of course it's rock but it's
not you know what we need
you know how we have a lot of men like
my neighbor i still have a lot of men
that come around every so often and i'm
super happy when they come
around you know we need we need we need
to dim some ladies with the carts but in
the neighborhoods oh
[ __ ] wouldn't that be sick just going on
every time people just get beat up
she's spreading the corona
in japan they have a uh the ramen man
and back in the day
like the ramen man had like a box on his
scooter
and then he would play the trumpet like
that real ramen or the instant noodle
ramen ramen yeah and then so like he
would play his trumpet
and then that would be his like ice
cream truck kind of sound right and you
go outside and you'll be like yeah
porn yeah like yeah but there was a
there was a there was a song that they
would play
like miles davis
oh it's the ramen man it's the jasmine
guy yeah and then you they'll they'll
set up their little
like ramen station on the back of the uh
scooter and you can just eat it right
there
cool but now it's just ramen delivery
so they'll have a scooter and they'll
come over and just deliver too it's not
the same
yeah it's just not the same it's not the
same ramen for lunch
guys can we can we not do that again
i am so sleepy right now what's great at
night i feel ramen is perfect at night
it is pretty heavy oh my god i'm so
sleepy
listen i'm sorry i was the one that
suggested silver like ramen i love it
it was delicious i'm just saying holy
[ __ ] i was so disappointed that i didn't
change my food order and i didn't even
get the ramen
damn wait what did you get i got the
chicken the the delicious
gyoza damn it you got you got all the
fried foods i did
i forgot to change my order but anyway
oh i [ __ ] miss
traveling now and eating foods all over
the world what if they bring the country
to you in a truck
yo that'll be amazing you go here's
egypt then you open it and there's like
two
like pyramids and a sphynx in the back
everything's scaled down
it's like a mini golf course yeah yeah
you know what they should do
okay you know how there's the rose
parade right we should have
like a food parade or something where
all the trucks
are like floats or like buffet stations
and they just slowly roll through the
town that's pretty cool
can you imagine it's like a parade right
and then they just stop
every five minutes so you can buy the
stuff and then they they keep moving
like a train
no i don't want them to stop you just
keep running after or not running but
like
keep the pace going so it makes people
move yeah
i like that or the opposite you can just
stand still as the food passes by you're
like i don't want that conveyor belt
oh dessert's coming dessert's coming and
then they drive but what if you it
passed like
what you wanted you're like they're like
the sushi floats up there and you're
like no
you gotta [ __ ] sprint to catch up to
it
no but people are smart they'll start
getting like the bird scooters or
something it'll be a fast lane
for you to go it's gonna be so dangerous
now all the scooters gonna be left on
the streets
yeah but that's a genius idea so my
friend um she's a food
uh vlogger right and so you know some
restaurants they don't have
seating so what she did is she
got this like pretty cool fold-out table
and seats and
umbrella like so that in the back of her
pickup
uh if she goes to those restaurants that
don't have
outdoor seating they'll just park right
there set up
and then they'll have hot fresh food
cool that's how serious they
take their like food you know but i'm
like dang it food does change
taste like drastically when you take it
can't wait till you go home you gotta
set up right there
you often eat in the parking lot but
like in my car yeah but it's much better
when you can sit down on a
bench and like you know i don't like
eating in my calm like this it ruins the
experience for me there's something so
sad about eating in your car
yeah it's like depressing like like it's
a secret like a junkie
yeah yeah but if you eat in the trunk
all of a sudden it's kind of fun
that's cool yeah if you get your legs
hanging out yeah you know like the
things are dangling
it's weird you have to have like the
right kind of trunk because like in my
trunk i couldn't do it
you can't do it on your trunk you're
trying
[Laughter]
i know it's not comfortable to sit in
that's true
i guess it is kind of sad but i get in
my car a lot like back when i used to
work at the hospital and i would drive
out to go get my food i would just sit
in my car and eat it and how happy were
you huh
yeah yeah that's pretty sad yeah i would
do to take naps when i was doing my
internship back in my
corporate job the only reason i ate my
car is so i could
maximize time to fall asleep in my
little 30 minute window so i can sleep
as much as i can so hey you got to eat
and sleep in 30 minutes yeah
that was rough yeah 30 minute lunches
suck ass because it was like that at the
hospital too i'm like we should at least
have an hour that's what i'm saying i
think that's even out jobs
because then if you you can't do a sit
down uh lunch if
it's an hour like i'd rather give up my
my two 15-minute breaks
because they would give me a 15 30 15.
i'm like nah just give me an hour don't
you get like two hours in italy or spain
well they never work because they're
hallelujah
yeah sit down have a cigarette and
espresso that's what that's
like the european lifestyle like let's
work for two hours every day
so lazy so lazy but they're so
successful
are they yes oh they are
i don't know
[Music]
you